vous informons par ce mail qu'il sera
probable qu'un bureau d'abstention se
tiennent dans votre commune
c'est un drôle de mails que le maire
durci a reçu la semaine dernière une
demande de salle pour installer un
bureau d'abstention le jour du vote pour
la présidentielle
à l'origine de cette initiative un
collectif mené par franck randa
humoriste niçois connu pour ses prises
de positions controversées sur le net un
contre bureau donc pas vraiment du goût
de l'élu
au moment où les républicains les
démocrates appellent les gens à se
prononcer massivement pour les hommes ou
les femmes de leur choix et surtout sur
les politiques à mettre en oeuvre
je trouve qu'il est profondément anti
républicain de
de vouloir mettre en place des sortes de
contre bureaux de vote pour appeler les
gens à l'abstention l'humoriste veut
créer une abstention participative
regroupant les indécis en mettant à
disposition des urnes et des bulletins
je m'abstiens on dit aux gens vous ne
savez pas choisir parmi l'offre proposée
n'a aucun candidat qui vous convient
c'est dommage parce que vous avez quand
même envie que votre parole compte à
voilà donc je venais rejoignez un bureau
d'abstention est aujourd'hui le projet
est très récent il a deux mois seulement
donc c'est très très récent aujourd'hui
vous avez plus de 1200 personnes qui se
sont inscrites pour tenir un bureau
d'abstention la façon dont ils peuvent
tenir leurs bureaux d'abstention dans
leur véhicule personnel dans une baraque
à frites dans leur propre commerce chez
eux
le maire durci en appel à la préfecture
il souhaite qu'elle fasse interdire ces
bureaux non officielle dans les communes
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
tout à fait anti républicain je pense
même que c'est contraire au droit
puisque seul le maire a le pouvoir
d'organiser des élections
qu'est ce que vous ferez si en face de
la mairie d'abstention j'appelle la
gendarmerie parce que je tiens ce que
les élections se déroulent dans le calme
et que chacun puisse aller voter sans
pression extérieure